hi I'm Martin and I'm going to build and
deploy a react app to Google Cloud you
will see every step along the way so you
can do the same and deploy your app
anyone on the internet will be able to
use your react app and you won't have to
manage any servers let's get
[Music]
started the first step is to create a
react app then I'll create a serers side
app using Express that will serve the
react app to users and provide an API so
the app can get data from the server
finally I'll deploy the app to Google
Cloud first off I need nodejs installed
on my computer I already do uh but if
you don't go here to get
it next I will use vit to create a
default rect project
you may prefer nextjs remix or Gatsby
instead they all work V will ask me for
a project
name which framework to use in this case
react and type of
project now vit created a starter
project for me I can CD to this
directory it
created install all the
dependencies and run the
app the app is now served from my local
machine over this URL I will click and
there is my Rea app it displays a button
uh when I click it count is incremented
great the react app is working all right
uh let's make a small change uh I will
open the app directory then Source then
app. TSX uh this is typescript but it
would be a Javascript file instead if
you picked that language in the setup I
will edit this line here and save and
here we see that the app was rebuilt
automatically and here we see that it
was reloaded in the browser excellent we
now have an environment for local
development now let's build the app for
deployment I'll press uh contrl C to get
back my command
prompt then I'll run npm run build to
build the app for
deployment here we see the four files
that were created in the dist directory
those are the files that we will deploy
uh to the cloud later on all right that
was step one now we're ready for step
two we will create a serers side Express
app it will do two things one it will
send the HTML CSS and JavaScript files
from the dist directory to the user's
browser so they can use the react app
and two it will provide a serers side
API that a react app can call any web
app I have ever built has called an API
to access the database or to run other
serers side code to create that server
side app I'll go up one directory from
the react app then I'll create a new uh
nodejs
app this server side app will use the
Express package for handling HTTP
requests so let's install
that then I will create the file
index.js this server side code will
initialize Express so it can respond to
incoming HTTP requests and handle
Json then I will tell Express to serve
files from the dist directory as static
files and not try to run them um on the
server remember that directory contains
the HTML JavaScript and CSS files for
our react app
and then I'll add code to start the
express server so it listens to incoming
HTTP
requests let's add a serers side API to
our re app uh so it can call the list of
pirates when the app hits this URL this
code will run on the server first it
will extract the ID from the
URL then it will look up the pirate that
has that ID in our database if no pirate
was found it will return a 404 error uh
to the r
up but if the pirate was found that
pirate record will be returned to the
client as
Json
now in the finished app uh this get
pirate function we probably look at
pirates in a database but just to get
off the ground quickly let's hardcode
some Pirates
here
all right the service side code is done
let's run it on my local
machine it's convenient to have an npm
script for this so I'll go to
package.json for the server side app and
enter this start command we can use this
ourselves to start the app uh and once
we deploy the app to the cloud Google
will run that too
let's run that start command all right
uh the server is running on this address
on my local machine let's go there with
the
browser very nice our serers side app
sent us the react files so I'm now
running that app in my browser and next
uh let's take a look at that API I will
ask for pirate number three from from
the
API and there it is in Json format the
API is ready to be used by our R
app but let's move on to the last step
we're going to deploy this app to Google
Cloud first let's create a project in
Google Cloud for our app I'll go to
console. cloud.google.com
then I'll pick my account
here then I'll click through
here and and here I can click this
button to create a new
project if this is my first project on
Google Cloud I will also need to set up
billing uh we will use cloud run which
is serverless so it has no fixed monthly
cost it will only charge us when our app
is actively creating response to users
HTTP
request what does that mean well in this
chart uh our container is listening for
incoming HTP requests for the entirety
of the dark bar at the top
the blue bars are the requests the green
bars show what we're getting built for
as you can see when no blue request is
being processed there's a gap in the
green billing bars we aren't charged for
that time in other words if our app gets
1,000 requests per day and each request
takes one second to process we will only
be charged for 1,000 seconds of CPU time
that day we may even be charged for less
than that if some requests overlap
like the blue bars in the
graph the first 200,000 CPU seconds each
month are free with Cloud run there's
also free tier for memory usage uh you
can find all the details about the free
tier and the cost uh if you go above
that free tier here on cloud Ron's
pricing page in practice this free tier
means that none of my development
projects have cost me anything it's only
when I got serious production level
traffic that I've had to actually pay
for cloud run having said that uh for
the rest of the steps in this guy to
work you'd need to create your billing
account here if this is your first
Google Cloud project you get a $300
credit all right now let's get ready to
deploy the react and express apps to
Google cloud and that is done with a
g-cloud command line tool here are the
installation instructions I've installed
that tool already so I will authenticate
with g-cloud or login this will give me
access to my projects in Google
Cloud we see here that the g-cloud Tool
uh tells us that we should set our
current project that's a good idea uh
looks like we need our project
ID uh we can find that here in the cloud
console let's copy
that and then we'll use the g-cloud tool
to set our current
project
all right let's deploy our app to Cloud
run I'll enter gcloud run deploy and
that I would like the what I would like
the cloud run service to be called uh I
can have multiple Cloud run services in
my project the g-cloud tool will ask me
where the source code is it's in the
current directory so I will hit
enter then it says API run Google apis
com is not enabled uh to help with
security uh Google requires us to turn
on each API we want to use in our
project I will enter y to enable Cloud
rounding on my
project next I get to decide where in
the world this code will run any
internet user will be able to access the
app but it will be slightly faster for
users close to the location I pick us
Central sounds good to me so I'll enter
29 next it asks me if I want to create
an artifact registry in my project
that's where all the versions of my
built app will be stored making it easy
to roll back to previous version if
needed I accept by hitting
why this question won't come up next
time I deploy my
app now it asks me about unauthenticated
invocations to my app do I want my
application to be reachable by anonymous
users on the internet I do so I hit Y
again next it ask me if I want to turn
on cloud build again this question only
comes up because it's the first time I
deploy to this project uh Cloud build
builds my application actually a
container with my application from my
source code in the cloud that way I get
consistent builds in a stable
environment that does not depend on any
individual developer laptop I'll hit Y
again
and now it's building and deploying my
app this will take about 3 minutes so
I'll uh refill my cup of
tea and I'm back the deployment
succeeded and here it shows me the URL
that our app is served from let's open
that in a
browser look at that there's our react
app it is now on the public internet
ready for anyone to
use let's also make sure that the server
side API works
I'll enter SL API SL pirate SL2 after
the base
URL and there is the pirate record both
my clients side react app and the serers
side API work from the cloud we have
created a react app created a server
side Express app and deployed them to
Google Cloud for all the world to
enjoy now there are few more things
you'd need to make a good web app that's
ready for customers
your own domain name a database and user
authentication let's start with the
domain name the URL that cloud run
generated for us is fine for development
and testing uh but we'd probably want to
use our domain name before we send real
users to our app let's go to console.
cloud.google.com and our
project I'll click the hamburger menu
and scroll down to serverless and Cloud
run and here's our Cloud run run service
and any others we may create in the
future if I click the service I get this
page where I can view metrics uh set
service level objectives check the logs
and so on but we want
Integrations I'll add an
integration pick custom
domains here I'll enter my domain name
and enable some other
apis this will set up a load balancer
that points from my domain name to my
cloud round service it will also create
a certificate so people can use https
when accessing my
domain and it will show me the DNS
changes I will need to make for my
domain with my uh DNS hosting
provider I did all of this with my
domain and this is what it looks like
when it's
done there it
is by the way uh this load balancer will
carry a fixed monthly cost of about
$20 all right that was uh the domain
name uh what about the database well
there are plenty of choices in Google
Cloud if you prefer relational databases
you can activate Cloud SQL in your
project if you like no SQL databases you
may want to use fir store
instead by the way fir store is
completely serverless so it has no fixed
monthly cost and it includes a free tear
also client side code can connect to fir
store directly without a middle layer of
server side code if you
wish finally many web applications need
to authenticate their users let's talk
about that it takes a lot of work to
build login functionality yourself and
it's kind of dangerous too you might
leave a security hole open
I prefer using Firebase authentication
it lets users log in with existing
accounts from Google Facebook Apple
Microsoft and others or users can create
a new account for your app with their
own email and a password they pick Fire
based authentication takes care of all
of that for
you so there you have it the three steps
to publish your react app to the world
using Google cloud in my opinion the
best way to build an app is to focus on
your users and what they need don't
waste your time on server maintenance
networking scalability and so on uh
Google knows how to run production web
apps and can take care of all that for
you that way you can launch version 1.0
of your app
sooner and version 2.0 of your app will
be able to handle thousands or maybe
even millions of users because it runs
on Google's
infrastructure thank you for watching if
you have any questions please enter them
in the comments also let me know if
there are any other servess topics you'd
like to hear about in future episodes I
read every single comment I can't wait
to see what you
[Music]
build